Jimmy deserves a ton of credit pretty
for what he did this year
I think people talked a little bit about
how he was coming off to the ECL but I
also think that people don't realize
that was his first year playing
quarterback in this league you know he I
think he got three games in New England
and he got five games with us this is
his first time going through a full
season you know he had less games than
Baker Mayfield
going into a second year and to do that
with the pressure of also to me everyone
thinking you've already arrived and
coming off an ACL I said there was as
much pressure on him at the beginning
here as anyone I've been around and he
just took it handled it all year and got
better throughout the year and I was
very impressed with him that's Kyle
Shanahan 49ers coach at the Scouting
Combine talking about his quarterback
Jimmy Garoppolo the show is PFT live
NBCSN hello to our good friends in the
UK and in Ireland
watching the show is the show the show
on Sky Sports all right Peter this is
your fault the fact that we're talking
about Tom Brady possibly going to the
49ers your fault
I tried to light that fuse right after
the Super Bowl it didn't go anywhere
last week I thought that Kyle Shanahan
and John Lynch put it to bed and then
you had to write in your column on
Monday that Deion Sanders is talking
about the 49ers possibly pursuing Tom
Brady so I dust it off Tom currents in
on the act now the Boston Herald is
saying that the 49ers are a legitimate
contender I blame you but I loved every
minute of it cuz I think he should go to
the 49ers Peter what do you have to say
about it I think he shouldn't go to the
49ers now it did make a wonderful story
it really would and it could be that
Kyle Shanahan deep down thinks you know
I'll worry about 2022 in 2022 but give
me Brady for the next 32 games and I'll
take my chances we're gonna win a Super
Bowl now who knows maybe he's thinking
that I don't know I tried to talk to
Kyle Shanahan after the season he
preferred not to that's I was certainly
gonna ask him a lot about Garoppolo I
doubt I was gonna ask him so are you
gonna go after Brady you know because it
just seems totally preposterous that the
guy who you went and traded for manna
from heaven
dropped down and you got Jimmy Garoppolo
for a second-round pick and now you
would think about trading him
Derr by the way 50 minutes into the
Super Bowl Jimmy Garoppolo is 17 out of
20 the last 10 minutes he's 2 for 10 he
gets two or three passes batted down he
doesn't play well but really are you I
mean are we seriously going to say let's
get rid of Garoppolo for a guy who's won
six Super Bowls and it was the most
remarkable quarterback in NFL history
but are we really going to say that we
should dump the Garoppolo experiment
we've already paid them are we gonna
dump that and go for the next year maybe
or two and just go for it all and then
worry about 2022 in 2022 stop yes yeah I
know you like sit off your damn hands
move you're making the case for the move
Peter I'm not saying I'm not making a
case for the move I'm just saying I
would not do that at all I would not do
it I would keep Jimmy Garoppolo in his
first full year as a starter he had a B
to B plus year okay and in my opinion
he's got the potential to be one of the
best 10 quarterbacks in the league
consistently especially being coached by
Kyle Shanahan who is one of the two or
three best offensive minds in football
easily so to me I don't know why you
would give up security at quarterback
for the next ten years for what you hope
would be great for the next two I'm not
saying they're not gonna do it right I
doubt they'll do it but I just I
wouldn't do it
it's risky to me it makes me think that
if the 49ers are thinking this there
might be some Superbowl bitterness a
little bit by the way Jimmy Garoppolo
did play you know we Peter I'm with you
now I wouldn't do it either I wouldn't
you know if Kyle and my buddy Kyle
Shanahan asked me I'd say no net and
negative ghostrider
listen could you make a case is it very
close between Jimmy Garoppolo and Tom
Brady riah do I believe Tom Brady would
have played better in the Super Bowl
than Jimmy Garoppolo okay yes I
believe that I'm not so sure Tom Brady
could have done some of the things
though to get them there the Jimmy
Garoppolo made happen during the year
all right that stuff you mean all those
handoffs against the Packers well Oh me
no I mean no I mean all those third and
16s and those clutch drives at the end
of games and the and being the best
fourth quarter team in football that's
what I mean okay snarky comment now be
cool right and then the other thing to
what Peter is talking about okay is what
there's two things that would scare me
if I'm the 49ers and even scare me if
I'm Tom Brady you know first off this
would be it's gonna be the hardest you
heard me say this Mike it's gonna be the
hardest offseason ever in Tom Brady's
history if he wants to go to the San
Francisco 49ers it'll be the toughest
offseason he's had since his rookie year
in the NFL he is going to have to go
live inside the San Francisco facility
and learn a new system in a language
when he's only known one language his
whole 20 years of his NFL life added to
the fact this to be my last thing I'll
say about it is that you know Jimmy
Garoppolo and Peter made the point this
his first year as a full starter he's
only gonna get better I can promise you
Tom Brady is not going to get better
it's going the other way
so you have to take that into account
too and yes there's great risk by yeah
getting rid of Jimmy Garoppolo bringing
a polarizing figure like Tom Brady into
your locker room having to deal with the
fanfare the media all that he wants
things done this way it could really
upset the chemistry of your team let
alone we know how much Jimmy G is loved
by his fellow teammates on the team so I
think it is very risky and I'm with
Peter on this one I wouldn't do it and
and out of the fact I just want to see
Tom Brady back in New England I don't
want to see him in another uniform I'm
sorry 49er fans or anybody that wishes
that but that's just where I want to see
him I recall the conversation we had
after the NFC Championship game and the
49ers players were coming out in
defending Jimmy G Peter King hit the
nail on the head by saying what else are
they gonna say they have to rally around
their quarterback they're not gonna come
out and say oh thank God he didn't have
to throw the ball all day and I think
back to the game against the Vikings and
we were there Chris yes and you and I
both came to the conclusion the Kyle
Shanahan got freaked out by Jimmy G
having three interceptions that could
have
one was picked off by Eric Kendricks two
others could have been picked off by
Kendricks and it was after the third one
that they went into the run the ball run
the ball run the ball run the ball mode
and they stayed in that mode for all of
the NFC Championship game now look we
don't know what Kyle Shanahan really
thinks about Jimmy Garoppolo is he smart
enough is he adept enough can he make
the big throw in the big moment Peter
you mentioned he was a B ravit plus last
year over the course of the full season
I don't disagree with that but with the
championship on the line in a pass/fail
moment and Emanuel Sanders as Bruce
Arians would say wide-ass open going
into the end zone Garoppolo missed him
Tom Brady doesn't miss that throw if I'm
Kyle Shanahan that's the thing that is
haunting me now and that's the thing
that if Tom Brady wants to play for me
that's how this would get started I
think Brady makes it known he wants to
play for the 49ers it makes it hard for
me Peter to say no if we were going to
judge a lot of people on one throw how
about the throw that Tom Brady under
threw to Gronk thank that was
intercepted by chase Blackburn in the
Super Bowl I mean look I there's you put
the game on the line what about the with
the game wasn't on the line without
blast it was like the last series of the
game it was like the last or second last
series of the game but but be that as it
may be that as it may
we're talking about everybody is talking
about set you know having a 43 year old
quarterback go somewhere for a year or
two versus a RN who knows maybe it could
be four years but everything would argue
against that other than the brain and
they and the whatever the muscle
structure of Tom Brady but but my only
point about all this is you've got a
gift from God in Jimmy Garoppolo which
you've got incredibly cheap he just had
his first year as a starting player and
he played well he put up 48 points at
New Orleans it's it's just you know it
would be one thing if we were talking
what about Mitchell true Biscay
we're not we're talking about a guy who
had a good year right who can probably
get better and probably will get better
and who has 10 or 12 years left to play
football I just I just do not see the
logic here at all yeah III think it's
risky to you know I do and you know
again how you know with Tom Brady but he
hung in the pocket like Jimmy Garoppolo
did when both offensive tackles got hurt
for the San Francisco 49ers listen Mike
I know
Shanahan changed his game plan calling
and things like that in that Vikings
game you know because he got scared
listen I I think there's moments during
the year that in the New England
Patriots changed the way they were
calling the Begay the games too because
they were like man Tom's not gonna stand
in there and make this throw Tom's not
gonna push the ball he's gonna be
conservative here so there's those
issues too Brady is not perfect I mean
let's not forget his last game he was 20
of 37 you know it wasn't like we're
sitting here going oh man he is still
dicing him up you know and again I'm not
trying to disrespect Tom Brady he's
amazing that way and for Tom Brady you
know again I think what this does to me
more than anything this rumor this
talking point which seems very real like
we were talking yesterday butter smoke
there's fire
like with Brady of course he wants to go
to the 49ers this confirms this is a
legacy move he's looking for it and this
confirms to me that it's like ok the
49ers of the Titans or is going back to
the Patriots he's only going to go
somewhere where he can win a Super Bowl
the 49ers arguably are the best roster
and complete most complete team in all
of football so I understand him wanting
to go there but I'm again I live with
Peter here I think it's very risky to
make that type of move with a guy like
Jimmy Garoppolo who yeah it's not
perfect but it was the 8th rated
quarterback in football and I think
trending upwards as compared to a guy
where yeah he's a legend and you know
maybe the greatest of all time I get
that but he's still 43 and he's going
downwards and that's just the simple
facts of the matter I'm surprised that
this issue has been on my radar screen
for nearly a month and I haven't pulled
up out of curiosity the San Francisco
49ers opponents for 2020 until just now
they play the four teams of the
FC East and the four teams of the AFC
East including at New England guys Wow I
think I'm rooting for a little bit
harder that would be I was when the
segment began right here's the thing
okay let's it let's just assume let's
assume that Brady makes it known he
wants to play for the 49ers and Kyle
Shanahan and John Lynch realize we can't
say no to this we don't want to be like
the Texans in 2012 who said no thanks
Payton will stick with Matt Schaub what
do you do with Garoppolo if it comes to
that Peter I mean I would if I hey look
if they really did this I tried to trade
him back to Belichick and see if we
could make that work the biggest problem
with that is I mean and and I think it
is a big problem is that you know the
New England Patriots basically do not I
think they would have to work on the
contract in that case because the New
England Patriots I mean I talked about
it earlier in the show and I've written
about it two or three times now we in my
opinion the Patriots are gonna sit out
this dance of overpaid quarterbacks
right and they're gonna wake up on May
1st and they're gonna see ok who can we
get to come in here for one year six
million Jameis Winston Marcus Mariota
I mean whoever is out there there's
gonna be three or four guys who started
in the NFL who are gonna be out there
who don't have a chair after the music
is stopped for musical chairs so that
that to me is much more of a Belichick
way now the thing that would that would
be different in this case is that Bill
Belichick loves Jimmy Garoppolo loves
them and so if Bill Belichick loves
Jimmy Garoppolo maybe all bets are off
but I think it would be hard to make
work financially in the cap situation
the Patriots are in now well it's
another fascinating development that
we're going to be keeping an eye on over
the next two weeks and two weeks will
fly by and we should know by then at
least have a feel by then where Brady is
leaning toward going we'll know whether
or not he's gonna go back to New England
within the next two weeks and does he
end up in San Francisco given that the
49ers play at the Patriots they
share my goodness that will be something
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports